god
okay
so
um
okay thank you very much everybody
so we have some very interesting news
kevin kleinsmith a corrupt
fbi attorney who falsified
pfizer warrants james comey's
very corrupt fbi is expected to plead
guilty you probably heard that it just
came out
so that's just the beginning i would
imagine because
what happened should never happen again
so
he is uh pleading guilty
terrible thing terrible thing
fact is they spied in my campaign and
they got caught
and you'll be hearing more today the
office of trade and manufacturing
policy released a new report on how my
administration has
harnessed the full power of the defense
production act
to achieve the greatest industrial
mobilization since world war ii
in our fight against the china virus new
factories businesses and laboratories
are being built all over america to
match our nation's demand for personal
protective equipment pharmaceuticals
drugs
testing supplies therapeutics and
vaccines
it's been incredible what we've been
able to do in a very short period of
time
we're helping other countries also
because we've been
really uh we've been doing it at a level
that nobody's ever seen before
it was just announced a little while ago
industrial production
rose for the third straight month it's a
big thing
factory output was up 3.4 this month
after a 5.7
increase last month those are getting to
be record numbers and manufacturing
capacity utilization
is now up to almost 70 percent
so we're coming back very strong we
should have a very good third quarter we
should have
an unbelievably good next year next year
if
we don't mess it up with somebody that
has no idea what they're doing
could be a fantastic year my
administration has
exercised the authority under the
defense production act to
a number and a related
authorities out of 78 times dispersing
over 3.5 billion dollars to speed the
development and manufacturing
of essential material so
put it a little bit differently the
administration's exercised the authority
under the defense production act and
related authorities
78 times that's a lot
peter right it's a big number 78 times
came in very handy a lot of times we
just mentioned it and they did what we
asked them to do
dispersing over 3.5 billion dollars to
speed the development and manufacturing
of essential materials
i've used the dpa more comprehensively
than any president in history
it was a time when the media would say
why aren't you using it why aren't you
using it well we have used it a lot
we're necessary only where necessary for
the most part
we've had tremendous cooperation by
invoking the dpa we mobilized the
extraordinary
productive might of general motors to
manufacture ventilators gm
repurposed the kokomo indiana plant in
just 17 days
an all-time record and has now produced
over 21
000 ventilators we're also
working with ford motor company and
general electric to produce
over 30 000 ventilators a month
in michigan they've done a great job our
nation is now the king of ventilators i
say that the king of ventilators we're
sending them all over the world
and helping a lot of countries that
could never have ventilators
and it's really i guess we're looking to
produce over 200 000 ventilators by the
end of the year
those are some numbers so uh we're
helping a lot of countries
in april i directed 3m to increase its
manufacturing of n95 masks
by may they had increased production by
over a million
masks a day think of that they increased
production of mass by over one million a
day
3m is now manufacturing an additional 39
million masks
a month we also worked with honeywell to
open factories in arizona and
rhode island they're now producing over
20 million masks a month
by the end of the year domestic u.s
manufacturing will have produced
over 1 billion n95 respirators
and all of them are made right here in
the usa that's a big difference from the
past
overall we've increased n95 mass
production by
400 million masks a year
now the media might say why not 500 why
not 600.
nobody's seen numbers like this ever
we delivered more than 75 million
dollars in support to
puritan medical in maine i was up there
as you remember we had a tremendous
visit and tremendous throngs of people
along the roads
on the way to puritan medical
puritans doubled their production of
testing swabs
from 20 million to 40 million per month
they're doing a fantastic job
and so is maine i've also used the dpa
to fight
price gouging and hoarding my
administration located and seized over
half a million pieces of hoarded
personal protective equipment including
299 000 pairs of medical grade gloves
192 000 n95 respirators and 130 000
surgical masks that's hoarding
my administration's decisive actions
have yielded truly
incredible results people have done an
incredible job
we've replenished the strategic national
stockpile
that was very badly depleted when we
took office and
totally neglected in the last
administration
since the start of the pandemic we have
tripled the number of n95
masks on hand to over 40 million triple
the number of gowns
over 15 million and quadruple the number
of ventilators to 69
000. by september the strategic national
stockpile
inventory is on track to contain over
300
000 excuse me 300 million n95
respirators
and surgical masks over 4.5 billion
gloves
and over 190 000
ventilators it's far more than we've
ever
done before it's not even close as
we talk about the economy we continue to
restore america's industrial might
we're bringing more jobs to the usa we
understand that the economic health is
critical very critical to public health
we'll be discussing next week some of
the
outstanding numbers we have compared to
any other country
there is no country even close when you
look at what we've done compared to
them on the stand from the standpoint of
the economy
and also during even during the period
of the
china virus in the last three months
we've added an
average of 100 000 jobs every single day
we've also added over 620 000
manufacturing jobs in the past three
months that's despite
people saying you can't do manufacturing
jobs anymore you'd need a magic wand
they said but they were wrong
weekly jobless claims just fell below 1
million for the first time
in a long time i'm pleased to announce
that as part of
operation warp speed the federal
government will be partnering with
mckesson corporation great company which
is a major medical supplier to
rapidly distribute a china virus vaccine
as soon as one is approved fully
approved they're in stage three trials
we have many of them going along
different
passes also many different companies
doing them
very very incredible companies we
currently have three candidates in phase
three
clinical trials and are in pace to have
more than 100 million doses of a vaccine
ready before the end of the year and 500
million doses very shortly thereafter
and we're ready logistically to
distribute them our military is ready we
have a
a great general who's in charge that's
what he does is he distributes things
usually it's people and weapons tanks
but in this case it's a vaccine or
therapeutic as it may be we
continue to actively monitor the virus
executing our strategy to protect the
vulnerable and prevent hospital
overcrowding as of today
hospitalizations continue to be very
stable
and we will be watching always very
carefully
remain vigilant we ask every citizen to
practice good hygiene
socially distance wear a mask when
distancing is
not possible and to protect the elderly
always protect the elderly
so now we'll take a few questions if
you'd like
yes mr president on the issue of
more money for the u.s postal service
and mail-in balloting
if the democrats were to give you some
of what you want which you articulated
in a series of tweets in the last hour
would you be willing to accept the 25
billion dollars for the postal service
including the three and a half billion
dollars they give us what we want
and so what i want is what the american
people want so in addition to
you know just i think john is part of
your answer i can read this
but in addition to uh the executive
orders that we signed which you're going
to be doing
terrific things in terms of uh payroll
tax
cut which is a lot of money coming to a
lot of people very quickly i've directed
the
secretary of the treasury to get ready
and send
direct payments 3400 for a family afford
to all americans
democrats are holding this up
i am ready to have
the ust and sba
send additional ppp payments to small
businesses that have been hurt by the
china virus
democrats are holding this up so we're
talking about
those are two things directly involved
and really victim of the china virus
we're
ready to send democrats are holding up
i'm ready to send rental assistance
payments to hardworking americans that
have been hurt by the
china virus all of these things are in a
list democrats are holding
this up i'm ready to send
105 billion to the states to help open
schools safely with
additional pppe
and democrats are holding this up so
that's 105 billion to the states to help
open schools safely with additional ppe
democrats are holding that up right and
i'm ready to send
more money to states and local
governments to save jobs
of our great police our firefighters our
first responders and teachers
it's all ready to go democrats are
holding it up so they're holding john
all of that up
so if they were to give you that yeah
would they sign off on the money for the
possible yeah but they're not giving it
to me they're giving it to the american
people i mean
giving it to agree with that yeah i
would i would certainly do that you
i would do that you know follow up on
that and then a
quick question just when you said that
you've directed secretary mnuchin to
ready direct payments are you
are you speaking about something you're
going to do independently or that you're
just waiting for the list i'm waiting
for the democrats to approve it
okay and then i would ask you and you
congratulated hardly marjorie taylor
green in a tweet
you called her future republican star
and green has been
a proponent of the q anon conspiracy
theory she said that something that
should be
would be worth listening to do you agree
with her on that well she did very well
in the election she won by a lot she was
very popular
she comes from a great state and she had
a tremendous victory so absolutely i did
congratulate
her please go ahead what's going on
you agree with her on that that was the
question i just wanted to ask you
what ails your brother robert and how's
he doing
uh i have a wonderful brother we've had
a great relationship
uh for a long time for from day one
it's a long time ago and uh he's in the
hospital right now and
hopefully he'll be all right but he's
he's pretty uh he's having a hard time
i wanted to ask you also really quickly
about um putin's invitation to join a
video summit with iran and other world
powers
would you accept that invitation i
haven't been told of it yet
i heard there's something but i haven't
been told of it yet
thank you mr president two questions on
vaccines
first once a vaccine is ready who should
get it first
i will rely on the doctors to tell me
that
i would say probably the elderly i would
say nursing homes
a lot of people said would you take it i
said i'll take it if they want or i'll
go first or last i'll do whatever they
want me to do
but i would think that the elderly the
people that are
most vulnerable to the disease and we're
actually making those lists right now
mostly nursing homes and retirement
centers russia has approved a vaccine
what do you know about the vaccine have
you spoken to russian officials we don't
know
much about it we hope it works we do we
hope it works
they've cut off certain trials
and we just feel it's important to go
through the the process we have
numerous different vaccines that we
think are going to work
but we want to go through a system of
trials we're very advanced we're very uh
we'll be announcing something in the not
too distant future also with
therapeutics which i think are very very
important yeah please thanks mr
president i had 2-1 on
china and one on oil the first one on
china
uh there's a lot of alarm among american
companies about your order on wechat
apple for disney they're worried because
it's such a big communications platform
and a payment platform in china
that if you ban us businesses from
working with them that they won't be
able to sell
you know iphones into china or similar
markets
whatever so you don't mind if this is
how to do what's good in terms of the
security of our country
so we've had problems we've been very
badly let down by china what's your next
question
an oil uh the us this week seized four
iranian oil tankers going towards
venezuela
yeah they're they're going to go to
houston i'm wondering what you're going
to do with that oil and if this
is we'll be announcing we have four
tankers they're going to houston
and uh they're there uh we they're not
supposed to be doing that iran's not
supposed to be doing that and
uh so we did we seized the tankers and
were
moving them and moved to houston mr
president thank you so much two
questions if you don't mind mr president
first of all pablo harris
you've been very blunt about how you
feel about her mean nasty mad woman
biden now saying i said
she treated joe biden worse than anybody
else i watched those debates they were
very boring but they were debates
nevertheless
and i watched you know pretty good parts
of them and
she treated biden worse than anybody
else by far
there was nobody including pocahontas
nobody treated biden so badly
as kamala well let me ask you this then
do you
have an issue with a strong woman of
color being
in this presidential race you don't see
her as a surrender as you
know none whatsoever nope not at all
thank you mr president and a stimulus
question if you don't mind
you have told me even before you were
president you always talked about being
the ultimate deal maker
why not just sit down with democrats
personally and cut a deal
because they want one trillion dollars
to go to their friends doing a bad job
running certain cities
and states that are doing very badly you
know most of our country is running very
well
even in terms of crime most of our
country's setting records in terms of
low
but when you look at chicago when you
look at what's going on in illinois and
new york and other places
uh both economically and in other ways
it's horrible
it's horrible look at oregon look what's
going on in oregon they have
i don't think they have a clue we could
stop that if they would request it we
would stop that problem in one hour like
we did in
minneapolis we would stop it in one hour
it would be over
it's so easy to do all right please go
ahead in the back please
uh alicia powell at the gateway
yesterday you announced the historic
peace deal between
israel and the united arab emirates and
later in the day joe biden
tried to take credit for this that was a
beauty
announced the deal and i appreciate it
even the new york times gave it great
coverage and editorials today
uh wall street journal washington post
everybody was saying
great and this is something we've been
working very hard on
and i saw where sleepy joe tried to
claim credit for it i'm trying to figure
out how that one works
no what he did is they made a terrible
deal with iran
and the deal was a horror show and i
ended it they gave him 150 billion
dollars for nothing
they gave him 1.8 billion dollars in
cash for nothing they got nothing from
that deal except trouble
uh they did nothing uh they're just like
they've been weak on china they've been
weak on russia
they've been weak on everyone and they
were the weakest of all on iran
uh no that was a great deal made by very
talented people that work with me
and it's been praised all over the world
and what you'll see now is
other countries will come into that deal
and you'll have peace in the middle east
and biden doesn't even know he doesn't
even know the name of the countries i'm
talking about
thank you very much everybody
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh
you